What a person chooses to drink will reveal a lot about him.
Martini, shake well, don't stir.
If they order whiskey, it means they are cool.
If they order a fine Chardonnay,
They are likely to go to class...
But there is a drink that appears in the movie and needs some explanation...
I see you drink 1% milk because you think you are fat?
Maybe when you think of milk, the first thing that comes to mind is youth and innocence.
When a 16-year-old teenager uses his charm and wind vacation dress is a pilot,
The drink he chooses will remind us that he is not yet adult.
What do you want to drink after taking off?
milk?
In the "clockwork orange", the teenagers drink milk,
The side reminds us that all this confusion is caused by the children.
James Dean drinks milk in this way.
This is a visual reminder of his conflict between maturity and adulthood.
Of course, if you don't drink milk, it means you are very masculine.
How strong is I?
I have a bowl of nails for my breakfast today...
Yes, then?
... no milk added.
Hey.. This road on the right. Sorry to keep you waiting.
If you want to have an in-depth interpretation
It can be argued that in the "little home", Kevin spilled a bunch of milk
Is a symbol of his lack of maternal love
Or you can say
John Hughes just wants to tell a visual joke
Everyone will worry about the spilled milk
However, this is just about the fur of milk.
Many adults also drink milk, this is
Where milk becomes more complicated
Milk is a symbol of childishness, so see
This killer is not too cold and powerful.
Leon feels very humorous when drinking milk in the movie.
It fits nicely to
Movie comedy moment, but it also
Revealed his love for the girl when he will
Matilda is protected under his wings.
Drinking milk in this scene is a joke, but
Many times drinking milk has
The opposite intention: this is creepy.
An adult man is very milk revealing what
The film producer seems to be
Know this intuitive
In Hitchcock’s "suspicion"
The audience suspected that the milk might have been poisoned.
This is very weird
Let us think of innocent and pure milk, it may have poisoned
This may be a poisoned drink.
I don't think this will have almost the same effect
If you change it to coffee or a cup
Shot of the whiskey.
Have some enjoyable scenes
Make milk dangerous.
We saw again in the "shameless bastard": Colonel Hans
Drinking milk from LaPadite Farm
Has a creepy effect
But there is more content than this.
I quote the words of the social theorist Roland Barthes.
He picks up the milk: its purity, the innocence of the child, is a symbol of strength, a force that is not tempting, impulsive, but calm, pure white, transparent,
So when a bad guy is holding a glass of milk,
This is creepy, but it also shows
Their power, they show them by drinking milk
Conquering purity and innocence
And not a little bit
When I saw "Crazy Max: The Road to Fury"
When people are only afraid in the theater
Not in a violent scene
But when this scene happens,
Western culture is repulsive to breast milk,
It is considered taboo for adults to drink breast milk.
...... taste a little bit odor
This is because it is the left breast from Debby
Collecting milk shots in the movie
Further alienation
The post-apocalyptic world and our world
In summary, "Crazy Max: The Road to Fury" is a story
Liquid movie. Women are because their breast milk is being used
Men are used because of their blood
People are being used
Because the water supply is controlled
Full control of these liquids shows
Immortal Joe's rule over the world
Milk is no exception
In fact, his son drinks milk
To keep their muscles stronger
Further emphasized that the consumption of milk symbolizes
power
The great thing about using these liquids in movies is
It makes
Crazy Max introduces the plot and
Other characters are not only verbally moved
When Max started his first selfless act
Furiosa, he washes his own milk,
Symbolizes the beginning of his transformation
Transforming from a selfish person looking for survival
a person who cares and takes care of others
The turning point of fully trusting Furiosa is
Max lost his blood to her.
Another symbol of liquid "Crazy Max: The Road to Fury"
Is a typical example of milk enhancing visual storytelling
Milk is a powerful storytelling tool. It can be displayed
Someone is a child, but it can also be
Show the power of the character
Or provide relevant plot information.
So next time you see one
What do people drink, ask yourself:
Is there milk?
Thanks for watching.